ضخمج هي احدى المدن الهمه في الوقت الحالي
في المعركه او في الحرب الروسيه
الاوكرانيه مدينه باخم تشكل منطقه يمكن ان
تكون مركزا كبيرا لقوات الروسيه للانطلاق
للسيطره على منطقه الكرامه موتورز لذلك
تستميت القوات الروسيه للدخول الى هذه
المدينه وبالمقابل القوات الاخرانيه في
الدفاع عن هذه المدينه هجوم كبير جدا شنته
القوات الروسيه على مدينه باخوت وليس فقط
على المدينه نفسها وانما على كامل جبهه
باخبط عندما نقول جبهه نتحدث عن حوالي 12
بلده في هذه المنطقه الان يحاول الرؤوس
السيطره عليها همم بالفعل استطاعوا ان
يسيطر الان على اوبتنا وهي مدينه متاخمه
او قريه متاخمه تماما لحدود مدينه باخ
متنزها قاموا بعمليات قصف واسعه جدا
بالدبابات بالمدفعيه النفاثه بقذائف
الهاون وكذلك بانظمه اطلاق الصواريخ
المتعدده الوضع صعب جدا تحدث بنفسي الى
احد الضباط في باخبط المقاتلين في منطقه
باخد وقال ان الوضع حار جدا في هذه الجبهه
منطقه سولدار منطقه افديفكا جميع هذه
ايفانا فك جميع هذه الكره الان تتعرض
لعمليات قصف ومحاوله للتقدم من قبل قوات
الاتحاد الروسيه لذلك هو بشكل عام طبعا
نايف الجبهه دونيسكا الان تشتعل حتى وليس
فقط في اتجاه همم ليس فقط في اتجاه باخذ
ومنها في اتجاهات اخرى كم منطقه همم
بافدين ايضا هنالك شرسه جدا وكذلك
يعني همم
بحذف ربما لانها اخذت همم الكثير من من
الاهتمام خلال الساعات الماضيه في همم
يعني وسائل الاعلام الحديث كده عن الوضع
العسكري كذلك للقوات الاخرانيه في جبهات
القتال في هذه المنطقه كيف يمكن وصفه وكيف
يمكن تقيمه ايضا
نعم يعني بحسب مراقبتنا وتحليلنا طبعا
البيانات التي تصدر من الجيش الاوكراني
كذلك من المسؤولين الاوكرانيين خاصه
الرئيس الاوكراني فلاديميرسي يبدو ان
هنالك يعني الوضع حرج جدا وهنالك نقص في
الاسلحه وفي الامدادات لذلك دائما يحث
الرئيسكي الغرب على مزيد من المساعدات
العسكريه حتى الحديث الان من الرئيس
الامريكي عن ان الروس يبحثون عن هدى
لاستعاده القوه هو انما حديث لحث الغرب
لمزيد من المساعدات لان الجيش الاوكراني
هو في حبه الاستعدادات للتقدم ولكن ينقصه
السلاح تنقذه ال- ال- ال- يعني الصواريخ
لانظمه هذه مارس وناس وكذلك همم انظمه
الدفاع الجوي والزخائر والكثير من الاسلحه
همم طبعا القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه تقول
ان لديها العدد الكافي وظل وما يزيد من
الجنود ومن المقاتلين ولكن ينقصها اسئله
همم الوضع طبعا يعني عندما نرى ان قائد اا
المنطقه وحاكم المنطقه في لوغانسير جيجا
يحتفل بانه استطاع ان يوفر سياره للقوات
المقاتله في نجوس فهذا يعني طيب مؤشر لان
الوضع في الامدادات خارج جدا
الروسيه فادت بالتعرض محطه زبرجيا لقصف
المدفعي همم هذا ما يمكن عن وكاله الروسيه
بدات بتعرض محطه زبرج النوويه الى قصف
مدفعي وربما كان الحديث خلال الايام همم
والاشهر الماضيه حول هذه همم المدينه او
الاقليم المهمه الذي اعلنت روسيا طبعا عن
ضمه اليه كيف تبدو الامور فيزا حتى هذه
اللحظه هل هناك خطر محتق حتى هذه اللحظه
بالمنشات النوويه المهمه في زبروجين
نعم نعم في الحقيقه الخطر هو مستمر طالما
ان القتال القريب جدا من المحطه القتال
يدور في منطقه قريبه من المحطه هنالك قصف
قصف متبادل بالتاكيد من القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه ولكن طبعا السلطات الاوكرانيه
تقول ان القوات الروسيه تقوم بعمليه تزييف
لقذف المحطه نفسي
الصواريخ وتقول ان القوات الروسيه
الاوكرانيه هي التي تعمل على عمليه المحطه
ولكن القتال يدور في محيط المحطه في منطقه
قريبه جدا